the NFL set this up not Kapernick the
NFL the league office which took the
position during Kaepernick's collusion
grievance it doesn't get involved in
these types of things oh it got involved
they set up this workout and they told
Kaepernick about it yesterday hey you
got a workout on Saturday for any and
all interested teams and Kaepernick's
people said well how about Tuesday you
know teams are kind of busy on Saturday
during the season
nope it's Saturday well how about next
Saturday so teams have a chance to you
know plan for this workout nope it's
this Saturday so there's a lot weird
about this and the weirdest part about
it is Chris the NFL at a time when the
camera dick issue is gone it's over it's
done the NFL is the one that dusts it
off and puts it right back in the center
of the table for all of us to pay
attention to again yeah you're right so
there's two things that jump out to me
about that one
okay did jay-z play a factor in this a
little has he been working it behind the
scenes a little bit alright I mean
everybody criticized him as being a
sellout and I did not agree with that
okay let me just say let me see if he
did if he did we'd know about it
maybe we was criticized for would never
want to look like they're listening to
somebody like jay-z and letting him call
the shots oh I don't know if I totally
agree with you there but okay can't keep
jay-z from leaking that he had
fingerprints on this and I guarantee you
he would know that's fair I mean it's
fair and you'll see you're right I mean
we will eventually hear if that maybe
was part of this and that jay-z was
working that angle okay so that's the
other thing that's the first thing the
second thing is okay and I'm with you
when I first saw it I was like man what
this is seems like a propagandist but
you know move all together the second
thing is it does make me wonder if teams
have been inquiring about Kaepernick
maybe to the NFL like hey do you think
we should flirt with the Colin
Kaepernick situation and do that and
maybe there's been some teams that have
talked to Roger Goodell in the league
office and how do you think we should
handle it so what do you think the
blowback
and maybe that's why the NFL decided to
set this up in a hurry to just maybe go
you know let's see what the public
reaction is to it now three years after
the fact and kind of gauge it from there
and then of course the teams can
evaluate you know hey a Saturday workout
- it's weird I get that that's very rare
coaches aren't always at workouts
anyways it's not a big deal
GM's don't need to be in buildings a lot
of gyms are going around the nation and
watching college football players right
now so they certainly can make
themselves available for the Saturday
workout those are just some of the
things that jumped out to me right off
the bat Mike yeah but making yourself
available on short notice when you
already have every planned out where are
you gonna be at practice what games are
gonna be out on Saturday right and
here's here's my take on it I think that
at its core this is either a clumsy
ill-advised PR play by the NFL because
again it was over it's done the agent
for Colin Kaepernick put out a memo a
few weeks ago addressing some of the
false narratives that have lingered for
the last two and a half years that
didn't register on anyone's radar screen
it's over why if you're the NFL are you
looking back at something that has faded
out of sight in your rear view mirror I
don't so I think the here's the better
explanation and I think it really is
this simple I think they're afraid he's
gonna sue him again and I think that
they're afraid that his lawsuit this
time will be better than the last one
because and Chris I learned this when I
was practicing law if you represent
employees whose rights have been
violated in the workplace that first
lawsuit is always tougher because let's
say you're suing for gender
discrimination age discrimination race
discrimination national origin religious
carbonation whatever it is in most
workplaces there are other people who
have those same characteristics who are
still gainfully employed so you really
have to have some proof that will
overcome whatever explanation the
employer gives the second lawsuit that
is followed by the employee who has sued
to keep his or her job or get his or her
job back that one's stronger because
there's only one person in the workplace
who sued to get his or her job back and
most employers aren't going to be
happy that they had to spend the money
they had to spend the time they had to
be they had to do something they didn't
want to do now Kaepernick didn't get his
job back but he got a pile of money and
he's able to continue to try to play for
NFL teams who are shunning him just as
aggressively as they were I think that
the league is scared that this thing is
going to end in another lawsuit or
collusion grievance or retaliation
grievance under the CBA and this is a
way to tip to at least play the game
it's a chess game between the league and
Kaepernick maybe he won't show up and
then maybe the case will be stronger
from our perspective if he doesn't check
the boxes and do the things that we
think he needs to do if we're trying to
kind of put him in a corner on this so I
think there's a legal strategy at play
here because they fear a second lawsuit
from Colin Kaepernick that's the only
explanation that makes any sense to me
well I mean Mike you know more than me
on these subjects a you know crap you're
smarter than me in general I do to me it
just seems odd are we recording do we
record this back at different over and
over again but but go ahead keep going
well it does seem like odd to me that
you can sue again for the same thing
that can you can't it's not the same
thing what you're suing for now is
retaliation that is being focused on the
person who exercised their legal rights
and essentially won he got somewhere
reportedly between 1 and 10 million
dollars from the NFL you're saying we're
determined even more determined now to
not give him a suit you're saying like
oh I sued you right and now you're
literally in the black book because you
tried just you sued us and won and
screwed us over so now you're saying you
can sue again because because of that ok
I get that under I don't understand that
get that logic all right they're dancing
or playing with fire here for sure I
know that because I just to me the other
thing that just jumps out and again the
legality this stuff I always leave that
to you and what you're saying it
certainly makes sense as you're sitting
here explaining it to me
but the other part of it too is what do
they do on Saturday like it's not gonna
be a good look of like two teams show up
or no GM show up I mean again that's
where it's just odd to me as the NFL
gonna call around certain teams and like
forced to GM's to be there to further
along this publicity stunt so it doesn't
look stupid because it's going to look
stupid if he's there and let's just say
to assistant GM's or to pro personnel
guys are there and he had a workout it
will totally look like a sham so
hopefully these are the type of things
that have been thought out I'm still
hoping that there's truly teams that
that are inquisitive about where he is
and actually do want to see him work out
but you know to what you have said and
yeah to what we've seen the NFL in the
past and some of their propaganda and
having to handle these situations I err
on more of what you're saying than what
I'm saying
and my understanding is that Kaepernick
is going to go through with it he's
asked for a list of the head coaches and
GM's who will be there because half the
teams are either traveling to play a
game the other half are going to the
hotel that they stay in the night before
the game there's a handful of teams on a
bye but he wants to know who's gonna be
there know how to be there none right
area but here's the thing you know these
private workouts that guys do before the
draft or pro day workouts when you have
a head coach or a GM there they can put
you through specific paces all right
this is something's gonna be run by
people from the Scouting Combine and
they're gonna send out the video to all
the teams well Kaepernick could do that
himself right and and that's the other
side of this - what's so weird about
this any team that wants to bring him in
for a tryout can do it any given Tuesday
I remember when Terrell Owens was trying
to get back in the league he was gonna
hold something like this they his own
workout I can't remember whether he did
or didn't do it but you can bring in and
teams do bring in five to ten to 12 or
more guys every week for tryouts in
their facility with the coach there with
the GM there cuz it's in the building
and no one's done that so that's what's
weird about this to me that's what makes
me believe that maybe there's some teams
that are inquisitive about it and they
don't want to deal with just the oh were
the team that brought them in pressure
and public scrutiny from the people who
were gonna fight out fight back about
Colin Kaepernick and his situation in
general and again I have no knowledge of
that but it's just something that
pops up to me they're just thinking
about it and reading your articles last
night and ever since the news broke last
thing to discuss on this before we take
a break and this question I don't think
we're gonna get an answer to but it's
worth pondering they had an owner's
meeting a month ago was this on the
agenda was this something that the
owners talked about decided to do do
they even know about it or is this just
the league office deciding on its own to
set this up I'd love to know how many
owners had input in this because my
guess is some of them would have said
why the hell are we doing this why are
we doing this why are we being the ones
to inject Colin Kaepernick back into the
news cycle in the middle of our 100th
season nobody's talking about this guy
nobody's worrying about this guy
nobody's thinking about this guy unless
they really are obsessed with managing
potential legal liability and let's face
it let's face it if he would sue them
again and they sell it again
I mean what's what's ten million dollars
enough to thirty two billionaires
carving this thing - it's like you
losing a penny yeah it means nothing to
them you're exactly right and you're
right so I don't know it's it's gonna be
interesting I'm gonna be interesting to
see just how many people show up how
many teams show up and what kind of
event this is overall well and Terrell
Owens should show up to catch passes
Antonio Brown should maybe show up to
pass that was he awesome partially with
tongue in cheek right he's gonna need
people to catch passes Antonio Browns
available Tio's keeps talking about
coming back at some point so what the
heck bring them both in
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports